and our next story is in mozambique
where an islamist insurgency has ravaged
parts of the country's north creating a
humanitarian crisis since 2017 militants
linked to the so-called islamic state
have been launching attacks in kabul
delgado province in march the militants
staged their most brazen attack yet they
seized the town of palmer after a
killing spree in which they beheaded
civilians
now authorities say they have flushed
out the extremists and it is safe for
people to return home
the guns have fallen silent but the fear
still lingers
mozambican soldiers say they are now in
control of most of cabo delgado province
but only after fighting escalated and
several african countries including
rwanda sent troops to help fight the
militants
one life lost is two men
rwandan president paul kagame on a
recent visit acknowledged that the
conflict is far from over
as much as we cannot be here forever
i think primarily the problem we are
dealing with
with the friends of mozambique
cannot stay here forever too
so as we solve the problem which
solidified this cooperation
we are definitely working together
fighting intensified in march when
militants linked to the islamic state
group took over the town of palma and
disrupted one of africa's biggest
natural gas projects
mozambique now faces a humanitarian
crisis
thousands have been killed and nearly a
million people displaced by the four
year long insurgency
although there are still pockets of
fighting the government says it's now
safe
and wants people to return
but many are still too scared and
traumatized
this woman was held prisoner by the
insurgents and only escaped when
government troops moved in
walked for
i reached the point where i couldn't
walk or breathe
i was so tired
i couldn't carry my baby
there was no water and i had to drink my
friend's urine
the government may have secured a
military victory
but it will take much more to rebuild
trust
and restore peace
and i'm now joined by johannes dietrich
she's a journalist who has just returned
from the province of kabul delgado it's
a place a lot of journalists are
struggling to get access to at the
moment so it's really good to have you
on the program uh johannes but what is
the situation
there in the region as you observed it
the situation is quite different there
is uh for example palma the little
coastal city um which is
back to normal almost it was only taken
by the insurgents for a short time but
right next to it is the big site where
the oil companies wanted to build or
want to build a big liquefied gas
company that there is no work
the construction has been
completely stopped and 70 kilometers
down south from palma
there's music
which was the capital of the insurgents
for almost a year that is completely
destroyed there is nobody living there
anymore it was quite a quaint nice city
and it's now all gone
johannes the government says that it's
flushed out the extremists and
authorities are actually urging people
to go back home to places like what
you've just talked about is the
government fully in control there
i mean the the government of musambi was
never fully in control and they have
been trying to flush it out for the last
five years they didn't manage so they
had to call the um rwandan soldiers and
they were quite successful at the moment
all the cities or the
um
the towns they are
back
in government control
and
and
but and that the people the insurgents
have left but the the question is the
the problem is they most probably they
just disappeared in the bush they were
not really defeated and they could come
whenever the um the soldiers go against
the ruined soldiers and
so they can't stay there forever
johannes human rights watch has just
released a report saying that children
as young as 12 some of them are being
recruited and trained to fight against
government forces did people tell you
about this when you were in cabo delgado
yes we were also confronted or shown
an an
assault or an insurgent who was perhaps
18 years old and he also said that he
was not voluntarily fighting for the
insurgents um but you never know um what
what is true i mean he had to say what
what the army told him he should tell us
and i'm i'm very careful um because the
tendency is in general that the
insurgents are portrayed as these brutal
sometimes foreign very kind of extremist
fundamentalists um who who can just be
fought and killed um but in fact
it is more that the population there is
is really from from the last 20 30 years
of complete
marginalization they are very frustrated
and
most of them are really locals and and
they they are the the they are portrayed
in the wrong way i think
all right that's the journalist johannes
dieterish thank you so much for that
johannes